you're mine it's morphin time we're
gonna sort I'm coming for you Rob you
can't hide behind that stupid mask
anymore and I'm going to keep counting
down these episodes
why because do that's why Power Rangers
Zeo wasn't always the best series as
evidenced in last week's top 5 worst
episodes but it had some really good
character stuff sprinkled throughout and
a pretty decent set of really strong
episodes I put the best of Zeo up
against the best of Mighty Morphin for
sure not saying it reached the heights
that those original three seasons did
but the continuation of this story
produced a few very well-done arcs and
retro actively made past episodes banner
as we got to see these characters
progress and change in these 50
installments throw me on my quest to
take down this disgraceful Dino once and
for all let's get this countdown started
as we do it these are the top 5 best
Power Rangers Zeo episodes number 5 a
brief mystery of time
Tommy keeps reliving the same day over
and over the other Rangers don't notice
this and pass it off as Tommy's own
paranoia later it's revealed that the
Machine Empire is behind the temporal
disturbance and the Rangers must find
out what they're planning before it's
too late I'm a big fan of the movie
Groundhog Day so it's no wonder I like
this episode so much it was nice to see
them try something different and have it
work this well it's a solid premise and
they sold it the right way when Zordon
and the rangers finally find out what
was causing the disturbance it was a
believable little payoff
plus the defeat protectron the rangers
used the warrior wheel it's always
awesome to see the warrior wheel Tommy
being the only one to detect time
repeating itself was due to his altered
brain chemistry since Prince gasket
brainwashed him in an earlier episode
for this series it's a decent excuse not
a lot of people talked about this one so
check it out for something different oh
you're adorable oh I'm so sorry I don't
have any Halloween candy but I'm here
Epis Victor Gadget sees Christmas at VHS
we're your parents little boy Doug it's
me Walter oh I'm looking for Rob why
because he did bitch to me oh that's
very good
haircut I barely have any hair in my
head I look like a freak Oh
number four good as gold as the intended
series finale of Zeo good as gold was
the official lead into turbo a Power
Rangers movie and the following season
Power Rangers turbo Jason is struggling
to hold on to the gold Ranger Power as
it is leaving him at a rapid rate
supposedly because his human form cannot
hold these powers for a prolonged amount
of time as both the Machine Empire and
dead and Rita fight each other for
Jason's fading powers Trey of tri forea
is contacted by the Rangers to reclaim
the gold ranger powers before they
destroy Jason entirely with King mondo
ready for a final showdown with the
Rangers our heroes are in as dire a spot
as they've ever been in before this was
a good ending to this season most
storylines are wrapped up but others
were started like Vulcan school getting
recruited for a big case in France and
leaving detective stones Private Eye
agency the next time we see them is in
the turbo movie and they're back with
stone on the police force there are more
unanswered questions in this zo slash
turbo transition but that's a whole
different discussion
Jason losing his gold ranger powers was
handled pretty well while I wish he
could have stuck around for the next
season this was a decent enough exit for
him as a series regular he did show up
with Kimberly in the turbo movie as well
once Trey gets his powers back from
Jason he helps the Rangers grow to giant
size for a final colossal fight with
mondo and a few it was satisfying
to see as Jason Rita and Zedd looked on
later Rita and Zedd blow up the whole
royal family and cripple the Machine
Empire's presence on the moon it seemed
like we were getting them back as the
main villain but we never saw that as
divatox took over the antagonist duties
the following season the finale of VO is
an exciting one I'd suggest it if you're
going back to rewatch a few episodes of
the series
tamra wait it's Walter I know thank you
shut up I'm looking for Robin Sheena no
what is the best as a fellow nineties
kid you know the evil about eighties
monstrosity has brought upon us before
now it's time once and for all a taking
my job I'm going to do it and I need
your help
number three the power of gold the
Rangers are in major trouble thanks to
King mondo splitting them up and
attacking them heavily with cogs as
things look their bleakest a mysterious
pyramid lands on earth and a Power
Ranger decked out in black and gold
saved the vo team from probable
destruction however as quickly as he
appeared he vanishes leaving the Zeo
Rangers with more questions than answers
this was the first appearance of the
gold Ranger and the mystery that
surrounded his true identity we also get
to hear that SiC Gold Ranger theme for
the first time which I love this episode
had a lot of action in it and was also
pretty light in the comedy we also get a
few interesting character moments from
Billy he's great in this series and the
end of the previous season upon
rewatching and seeing what a big part of
the show he was it's unfortunate the way
things ended for him on the series that
character really deserved more after his
development here I like that he's
filling his role in the Power Chamber
better than anyone anticipated but still
feels bad about not being able to help
fight with the Rangers in the field
while I loved Jason I would have been
pleased to have seen what Billy could
have brought to the gold Ranger it would
have made sense and just been cool to
see him back after being stuck in the
Power Chamber for so long this one is
great for the action Billy development
and gold Ranger stuff don't skip this
one on the rewatch no I haven't seen rob
sorry Walter I'm in Canada at Colorado I
really stink all right well thanks
anyway Malcolm hey did you get a haircut
snazzy
number two a golden homecoming crab try
forea can no longer hold the gold ranger
powers as his essence is split into
three entities he needs to pass on his
powers to a new host before they are
lost forever
Tommy returns to the power chamber with
a perfect candidate Jason Lee Scott the
former red ranger and leader of the
original Mighty Morphin Power Rangers as
the powers of the gold Ranger I'm still
within him the other members of the Zeo
team contend with the return of an old
machine empire robot named silo made
stronger this time by Neil plutonium
armor the new gold ranger soon joins the
fight and for Tommy and Jason it's like
old times once again this episode is all
about the return of Jason I have a very
clear memory of seeing this for the
first time I was so excited when Jason
was revealed as a new Gold Ranger
through the whole commercial break that
fouled I was jumping for joy I never
thought he'd be back on the show and
seeing him return is one of my favorite
moments from the entire series Mighty
Morphin included Jason and Tamy
reteaming as the gold and red Rangers
respectively was also a memorable scene
I love them as the red and green Mighty
Morphin Rangers and having them fight
the forces of evil once again was a
special treat their friendship is my
favorite dynamic on the show and the
ending scene where Jason explains to
Tommy that was tough for him to leave
the Rangers the first time was great to
see we re-established their bond and
Jason comes off like a true hero and
friend also telling Tommy he doesn't
want him to think he's going to take
leadership back from him Tommy reaffirms
to Jason that there's no one member of
the Rangers who's more important than
another it's a great scene if you're a
Power Rangers fan and only one episode
tops this store
[Music]
we
whoa hey back off oh thank you wait wait
Heather it's me Walter I am NOT going to
play Power Rangers with you this has
gone too far
now get out of the way I have a dull
thing to do wait wait wait
I'm just looking for Rob have you seen
him I thought he thought he was supposed
to be at the studio today
did you check there no thank you Heather
nice haircut by the way
and the number one best Power Rangers
Zeo episode is king for a day
parts 1 & 2 tommy has been kidnapped by
Prince gasket and brainwashed into
thinking he's the king of the Machine
Empire when bulk and skull tell the
Rangers out of costume that they had
seen Zeo Ranger 5 at the same beach time
he disappeared on they investigate the
matter which leads to Jason and Vulcan
skull being sucked into gaskets arena
once their Balkan skull team up with an
alien named try tour to destroy the
force field holding Jason in the arena
and the Gold Ranger himself tried to
convince the Mindwipe Tommy that he is
indeed a Power Ranger and everything
gasket has told him is a loss this
two-parter opens with a badass dream
sequence of Tommy's white ranger suit
coming to life in the power chamber and
attacking him the whole scene being
bathed in green light was a nice touch
when Jason and Kat go to the Mirage of
Tommy calling for help Jason mentioned
that he's let Tommy down once before and
he's not going to let it happen again
the attention to character with these
two is done so well we see that green
candle episode years earlier still
haunts Jason as his greatest failure
once Jason arrived in gaskets arena and
sees what's being done to Tommy he's
desperate to save him we even get a
little Tommy versus Jason scrap in part
two it's great to see bulk and skull
used so well in this episode while
they're of course mostly used for
comedic relief they have sometimes been
shown throughout the course of the
series to be heroic when the situation
calls for it that's the case here as
they team up with try door to shut down
gaskets forcefield and in the end they
once again save the Power Rangers
when the other four Rangers arrived at
the arena cat is the one who reaches
Tommy by powering down and embracing him
it's a great scene as the other Rangers
follow suit to help khamisi things
straight once again and realize just who
he is it's an amazing two-parter that
proves the show can be legitimately good
and fun when they focus on character
action and a powerful story Power
Rangers Zeo was a pretty good sequel
series to Mighty Morphin and it's best
it offered memorable moments and a few
exceptional stories just find out
they're releasing the goal Rangers power
staff and the legacy line and you must
believe I'll begin
seems like you had fun looking for me
today well look no further for I'm
always watching you with the eyes of a
mole and the ears of a snake if you ever
do another Power Rangers top five
I'll cut more than just your hair dine
over here Gilligan Rob where are you
come out and fight like a dinosaur this
isn't over
one day I'll have my revenge sucker my
head my pitiful hat I've had that thing
since I was a little Raptor I got to
turn it they dont sell it anymore cold
bastard
[Music]
you